hi cereal is a little bit too much of a
religious kind of project I'm using that
in the loosest possible sense and that
there is people who are devotees of it
because they love the idea that
conception Lindell thinks thanks for
being here
I'm Adrian Moore I'm vice president of
The Reason Foundation with me is Wendell
Cox who's principal at demography a he's
a consultant who's worked on
transportation issues for how many years
do you want to say more years and I
would long enough long enough to have
seen seen a lot of bodies get buried and
Wendell has worked with a certain reason
for I don't know it's been a good five
years or so since we started working on
the high speed rail project here in
California analyzing what's being
proposed and what crosswalking that
against what seems to be a reality and
trying to separate the hopes and the
dreams from some of the cold hard facts
we did you and your your partner in
crime jove rena CH did a study for us in
2009 2008 2008 was the first study that
was a very detailed analysis of the plan
as it existed then the the state of
California the high speed rail authority
has updated that plan since so last year
you and Joe collaborated on another
analysis of that update and found there
was a lot of the changes where a lot of
sound and fury but the the the crosswalk
with reality hadn't really improved very
much so well getting a little of that
but before before we talk about some of
the things that that you guys have
identified as being wrong with this
project I I thought there's there's some
interesting stories around this thing
anytime you're talking about building
something as massive as a high-speed
train line between Los Angeles and San
Francisco or I guess you know big
picture bringing in San Diego Sacramento
and and everything in between
a lot happens along the way and one of
the things the latest things that has
happened is as there's been a series of
lawsuits now most of those lawsuits have
been settled but one that Wendell I are
both expert witnesses in very
specifically charges that when the
high-speed rail authority in 2008 came
to the voters of California and asked
for ten point nine billion dollars to
fund the high-speed rail system they the
law that was the ballot measure that
California voters approved made a lot of
very specific promises it said things
like when it will be built how fast
it'll go where it will be built how much
they would charge so there was a lot of
very specific promises that they thought
they needed in order to get voters to
vote YES voters did vote yes
the current plan now five years later
violates every single one of those
promises and so the lawsuit says you
know really you can't spend that ten
billion dollars if the law that
authorizes you to spend the ten billion
dollars has promises that you have not
kept I mean that's kind of a contract
with the voters so we tackled parts of
that in our our our expert testimony
we'll see where that case goes these
things drag on forever
they really just got started in May so
it's a relatively recent case in terms
of getting in front of the courts the
one other thing I want to share about
that that I think is the most
interesting is a fellow named Quentin
coupe used to be a state senator for
California used to be a state judge a
was a Supreme Court judge but he was a
senior judge he was one of the first
chairman of the California high-speed
Rail Authority so he's the one who
really was in charge when the initial
idea got off the ground and in
preparation for getting that vote for
that initial ten billion dollars and
during that election I debated him up
and down the state and he was a vehement
vehement fanatical supporter of this
high-speed rail project and I was a
critic and so we butted heads a lot well
he has now joined that lawsuit as an
expert witness explaining just how awful
and
the current plan is so here's the most
maybe the most prominent high-speed rail
advocate in the state of California who
is now part of a lawsuit suing to stop
it
because the plan is so bad he doesn't
he's not against high-speed rail he's
against this plan and that's a
distinction I think a lot of people a
lot of people don't make Wendell's
partner Joe Vrana CH was back in the day
it was some time ago but he used to be
head of he was a director of the cat of
the u.s. high-speed rail Association
he's a high-speed rail fan and booster
he just doesn't like this plan he
doesn't think this is going to work so
that's really the crux of what I want to
spend a little more time talking about
is why is this plan so bad and why is
this thing not gonna work you know why
isn't a high-speed train between Los
Angeles and San Francisco just a crack
and good idea so let's just start with
sort of kind of a big maybe a big
picture I mean Wendell what do you when
you when you think about the the plan
for this project and what you know about
high-speed rail as it actually exists in
the world in China and Taiwan and Japan
in in Western Europe you know what's the
disconnect here what's the fundamental
difference about the California plan
that that stands out well I think first
of all let's step back to Senator
Quentin Kopp here the leading exponent
of of high-speed rail in California he's
a guy that's a very well respected guy
all of us would love to debate but he's
a very highly respected guy and he's
telling us he's against this thing now
and the very basic reason he's against
it is it's not high speed rail anymore
Quentin Kopp is a fan of high-speed rail
the legislature that promised the voters
in in the in the referendum that you
mentioned that this train would go 200
and would go from Los Angeles to San
Francisco in two hours and 40 minutes it
can't be done there is no way in fact
Joe and I in 2008 said it couldn't be
done even then what's happened is they
have scaled back the program from a real
high-speed rail program and their
problems with those to what they call a
blended system where somehow we're going
to run concurrently with the pen with
the Caltrain commuter rail program into
San Jose from Transbay in San Francisco
and when we get to Palmdale we're going
to get on the Metrolink tracks well you
know it's just not going to work and
that's why senator cop was it was it is
against it now but the thing that really
concerns me here and I've been bothered
about this for a long time on a number
of projects is that if Sam Walton had
made this promise to his to his
customers he would have finished his
days in jail the fact is that we had in
2000 the high speed rail authority said
we will build you this system it'll cost
22 billion dollars from Los Angeles to
San Francisco and before they scaled it
back it had reached 80 billion and this
is typical of what happens on these
things you can't you can't trust it and
just very quickly to end this this
section segment we worked with reason
three years ago two years ago looking at
the Florida high-speed rail program and
we made the same arguments and showed
all over the place that the the way the
cost escalation had gone and how the
record of high-speed rail is to make
promises to governments and voters it
can't keep and to his credit Governor
Scott a Florida canceled the system yeah
nobody's quite had the wherewithal to do
that and come on yeah it is kind of
shocking how they that the the the yo-yo
that this this project has been on so
they came out with a you know something
at a price tag you know 20 say 22
billion that people say wow that's a lot
of money but you can kind of imagine you
know it's gonna cost a lot of money to
build that big train and then you know a
few years later when they have to be a
little more realistic and they actually
have to put a business plan together
it goes up to 80 billion there's so much
shock and outrage over that it was it
couldn't have been three weeks later
they can't I said no no no okay
it'll only be 60 well first of all only
60 billion Oh only three times what we
originally said but then the fact that
they can just chop 20 billion tells you
they were making up the numbers in the
first place you can't just chop 25
percent off of the price unless you were
fake
the numbers in the first place and and
to get that they came up with this
blended system now for those you not you
know immersed in California
geography essentially what they're
saying is well we're gonna do a normal
speed train so to speak maybe a slightly
faster than average train from downtown
LA all the way out to the Central Valley
of California released to the desert and
then once we get to San Jose we're gonna
slow down to normal train speeds all the
way into San Francisco so it's only
going to be super fast allegedly 220
miles an hour between San Jose and
Palmdale Lancaster at best so in order
to reach the time the to meet that two
hour and forty minutes if they actually
went slow on those two bookends it would
train to probably have to go more like
280 through the Central Valley
technically not possible with current
technology so there's the whole thing's
just a loser there's it's the two hour
and 40 minutes was put requirements put
in there by the legislature because they
realized if this thing was not somewhat
competitive with flying in terms of time
people weren't gonna use it and once you
start getting up to a three and a half
hour train ride versus a 45 minute
flight even with the extra TSA time on
the front end of the flight and assuming
there's no TSA at the air at the high
speed train which is a big assumption
it's still a losing proposition so so
they they keep monkeying with this thing
is I think maybe our biggest beef is
that they're not serious about a plan
that really will work and then trying to
go to the to the people of California
and say okay look realistically this is
what it takes to build a high-speed
train are we gonna get behind that and
they know that that won't fly so they
keep trying to well you know they ran
with it yeah I mean and and Senator cop
was not the first resignation or was not
the first person who was on board to
jump off the train one of the most
respected leaders in the history of the
recent history of California Senator Jim
Mills of San Diego senator Mills is
father of the highly regarded light rail
program in San Diego senator Mills was
on the high speed rail
Kord and he resigned and when he
resigned he said the reason he was
resigning is because he didn't
understand what he was being given by
the staff and by the consultants and for
good reason I mean the the number of
things for example the very idea that
these guys still claim they can make 2
hours and 40 minutes now the neat thing
is for them of course when and if this
thing is ever built and it comes in at
350 which Joe and I think is the fastest
it can run nobody's going to jail so
what does the law mean but but the the
basic point is that the promises are not
going to be kept we've seen it all over
the place and by the way I mean this is
again something we see in infrastructure
projects especially rail infrastructure
projects around the world then fly berg
of oxford university has led research
with other european researchers where
they looked at these things and they
came up with a term for what happens
they call it strategic misrepresentation
and what happens is that the consultants
and by the way i saw this as a member of
[ __ ] translation of that lying they
put that in the academic report now i
what happens is the consultants and the
staff lowball the numbers because they
know if they told the truth you'd never
get approval and let me tell you about
the los angeles county transportations
commission that I served on the price of
the long beach light rail line which I
voted for and which passed the
Commission seven to four not a big
majority there's a lot of argument about
it was going it turned out to be three
times as expensive as what we voted on
that day in 1981 now if we had known
that that thing in 1981 dollars was
going to cost three hundred and eighty
or ninety million dollars instead of one
forty I guarantee you it never would
have been approved and that's it's funny
how every day somewhere there's a
business in America who's got a project
going where they when the board voted to
pursue that project they had a cost
estimate and when the cost got out of
control
they cut bait they say okay that we're
done
we can't sink any more Kostis and that
just it seems like the government just
can't do though you can't do that move
it yes I mean there wasn't I was on the
Commission for four more years we saw
the private cost going up I was the only
pointing the only one that didn't rely
on the electorate to get on the
Commission to get into another office
that would have gotten me a commission
no a public official is going to say I
made a mistake and we should kill this
thing whereas if you are working with
with investors money instead of
taxpayers money it's exactly what you do
turns out that the the repeated game is
different for elected officials than it
is for for for managers of corporate
managers in that and that's part of the
problem well they're just that makes me
think about some of the specific
promises that have been broken in the
current plan from the law that was
passed to approve funding this project
and I mean just just a few that stand
out in the law they said the fares would
be $56 one-way between San Francisco and
LA
the current plan says $88 the law
doesn't allow them to do that not even
be able to do that anyway and then yeah
the 88 would be the cheapest ride on a
high-speed train in the world including
China where where we know they're not
even remotely trying to charge what it
really cost another provision that I
thought was really I thought it was
really a big deal at the time though it
didn't get very much attention was that
they couldn't build any of it until they
had all of it they had the environmental
approval and others they'd gone through
the environmental impact report process
and got an approved environmental impact
plan for the whole thing they don't have
an improved environmental impact report
for any of it yet and yet they're
spending the money and they're going
ahead with building it and they say
outright in their current plan they're
gonna build the first segment without
the rest of the environmental clearance
flat-out violation of the law the law
said two hours and forty minutes they've
just taken that out of their plan and
now the lowest time that's actually
mentioned in the plan is three hours
realistically it's a lot more like three
and a half hours at best so they're just
plain violate so the violations law it's
I'm really curious to see we'll find out
in this case whether those kind of
agreements with voters are actually
binding in the state of California well
and the interesting thing is that when
when these when these promises were made
by the legislature in 2008 if anyone in
the legislature had said
now these promises are being made to us
the legislature not to the people of
California you can imagine the laughing
that would have been occurred but that
is what exactly is being argued by the
plaintiff IV by the attorneys for the
high-speed rail authority yeah so you
make you make promises to the voters no
the promises are really to the
legislature and they can say hey that's
alright to me it exposes you know one of
the fundamental problems with these kind
of giant I mean in some sense this is
true of all public works projects I mean
I think we've both seen this on much
smaller scale project but but you know
but they don't always do that I mean
there's been lots and lots of projects
have been built relatively competently
it's not inherent it's not inevitable in
the system it is inherent the the
possibility for this but the problem
with this is that high-speed rail is a
little bit too much of a religious kind
of project I'm using that and the
loosest possible sense in that there is
people who are devotees of it because
they love the idea the conception it's
not a practical thing for them it's like
this is the future other countries are
doing it we have to do it or else we'll
just be behind and you know we can't
have that in America and it's it's you
know refusing to sort of confront you
know these fundamental realities like
the very first time I heard about this I
thought gee you know at the time I
wasn't I'm still won't say I'm a
high-speed rail expert I just know a lot
about it but at the time I knew very
little about it but I could tell yeah I
know it's a function of population
density and and traveler density and San
Francisco to LA just just ain't it but
when I saw the proposal and I I got
asked to speak up and down the Central
Valley in particular because I live up
in that area to like tax payer groups
are normally very fiscally conservative
local governments and tax payer groups
who are saying you know what we support
this because frankly it's very rare that
the state of California does a big giant
project where they're gonna spend tens
of billions of dollars and some of that
money is actually gonna get spent in our
little podunk County or our little
podunk town so we're on board just
because for once in our lives we'll get
a little bit piece of the pie so they
basically the size and the scope of the
spending this project bought off a lot
of support that when these people of
course now have buyer's remorse
because the price tag is quadrupled and
there's no guarantee it'll ever actually
get built in their neck of the woods and
it's it's you know it's looking like it
was a bad deal all around when they
originally supported yeah you look at
one of the other one of the other
promises in the legislative bill that
was put that created the referendum in
2008 was it was a guarantee that only
certain amount of it would be built and
before there was funding put together
for it we do not have the funding we
need to build anywhere where I think
we're 40 to 45 billion dollars short at
this point this is on a project that in
2008 was going to cost 35 billion now
we're 268 billion I think it is and
we've still only got essentially 10 or
12 or something like that billion 14
with the federal money okay yeah it's
it's it's it's really crazy so so right
away we've got a real problem with the
funding and and then you know the
Central Valley
you know the very idea that talk about a
train to know where this thing goes from
Modesto not is it Modesto is that Madera
I think I think it's Madera Derek goes
from right now all they've got the money
to do is essentially madero to Fresno
they got to get more environmental
clearance to go to Bakersfield and some
of the movies oscillate Bakersville yeah
not quite Moscow or Curran or something
like that and and the idea is that
somehow if if we can't get the money
beyond that we'll turn it over to Amtrak
so they can run their San Joaquin
services over that'll be the most
expensive intercity rail system again
ever yeah get some use out of those
tracks yeah it's you know it's this this
this inability to sort of turn around
and confront it's it's like what you
were talking about with the the light
rail even as the cost went out right
under the public officials were we're
kind of in that same by now I mean
popular opinion has changed at the time
the ballot measure passed in 2008 to
fund it it was a fairly popular idea
they it won comfortably not by a huge
margin but the majority of Californians
said we want to build this train under
these terms now what we're partly what
we're chart what we're the reason we
were involved in slaw suit is because
they're not meeting those terms but
separate from that public opinion is
just turned against
this project you know the last last two
or three polls that have come out is
shown most people say you know what we
need to stop until we've got a plan that
will actually work and so far that is
not does not seem to have any impact on
the politicians or the decision makers
they are driving ahead because they've
got money they're driving they're
driving to spend this state bond money
debt money even though they're violating
the law in order to do so because the
federal government's made quite clear
look we gave you three billion we're
taking it back if you don't get
something built very soon that's the
other thing is the ballot measure that
that that California approved said the
thing would be done in 2020 yeah uh you
know well beyond that we'll be lucky if
they've built even that initial segment
wait yeah and beyond that the federal
money I can't remember the exact date it
needs to be spent by I think it's March
of 2017
now with all doing all that then they
have to start spending it by next year
yeah so that's what theirs is if they
don't well that's right man you've got
you gotta finish spending it but but by
March of 2017 let me tell you you don't
want to ride on a train that was built
in that exactly I mean the problems that
can occur but the other thing to think
about is the parts of this state that
have been forgotten I mean we've got a
metropolitan area in the south San Diego
of three million people we've got the
Inland Empire of about 4 million people
we've got the Sacramento area if 2
million people all these areas were
promised parts of this train and even in
2008 when the voters approve this thing
it was reasonable for them to anticipate
that this would be built in the long run
there's no way in the long run that
these areas are ever going to get
service so that the taxes that people
are gonna pay to service this debt and
by the way they're gonna pay if this
thing gets built they're gonna pay the
other forty five billion dollars do I
live in Illinois my members of Congress
and some of yours in California are not
going to allow forty five billion
dollars to come out of the federal
government so people in San Diego County
Sacramento County Riverside San
Bernardino County are going to pay
lotta money and get no benefit for it I
mean Congress actually just pulled they
just pulled out of the the next funding
request the high-speed rail funding so I
mean there's RIT right now the federal
government's not willing to spend a dime
on high-speed rail so this idea that
they're gonna give California alone
forty five billion dollars is pretty
laughable well that's the thing about it
I mean the the the GAO the Government
Accounting Office or Government
Accountability I did a little analysis
where they said well now what would it
take to give California all this money
they need and they compared it to the
federal transit program and some other
programs and the point is there's no way
that that amount of money would be out
there I mean we really do need to
recognize in the long run we're probably
not going to spend as much on some of
these programs as we have in the past
but California hasn't figured that out
yet yeah you know just one final piece
of fantasy because this really sort of
slapped me in the face I was at a
meeting in Washington where of course
fantasy is is a way of life and and and
the the advocates not not the California
project advocates but the high-speed
rail advocates were saying well here's
how it's gonna work you're you're you
know they're somewhat saying you know
okay some of your criticisms have some
merit but here's the deal what's going
to happen is this private company is
going to build this line from out in the
middle of the desert is 75 miles from LA
to Las Vegas people are going to drive
75 miles and then get on a train to
Vegas and that's all going to be done
with private money
never mind the federal loan that's going
to back all of the investment Solyndra
and but so so then you're gonna have
Vegas to LA and then they're gonna build
a line from that line across the desert
to connect with this one in Palmdale
Lancaster nevermind there's no right of
way through that part of the desert I
mean that nobody is even conceived of
that really but when that happens when
you connect Vegas to LA to San Francisco
then we're rocking that high-speed rail
and so forget about all your petty
concerns about the money and the
ridership and the cost and violating law
all that's beside the point when you
think about that how can you not do it
you say you know what that's when I say
it's a religious fervor I'm not sure
we're well they're gonna convince those
people with with
with any kind of numbers yeah and we've
we've done another report for the recent
foundation on this Victorville to Las
Vegas train and there is no place in the
world where anybody drives 75 to 90
miles to get on a train or an airplane
to go places it's 200 miles further 180
miles further ok and and now by the way
in in 2000 there was something called
the Las Vegas Monorail and I was hired
by some people in the Vegas area to
evaluate the project and I predicted
that it would go bankrupt in I think it
was three years and I I apologized right
now for the fact that it took 8 years
the fact is it was it the the
consultants were way off we have done a
report for reason on desert express
can't remember exactly how soon we said
it will go bankrupt but certainly within
10 years it can't make it it's very
simple even the International railway
Union which one might call the
cheerleaders of the industry says that
only two lines in the world have ever
been profitable one is Osaka to Tokyo
there you have many more people than
existing any corridor anywhere in the
world and it the population densities
are huge and the other is Paris to Lyon
and and and that's an amazing thing
they've done very well on that line but
nowhere else and all of that has been
government investment you think about
where there's been private investment in
high-speed rail there was the Channel
Tunnel I should say the well HS one from
the Channel Tunnel to to st. Pancras
every dollar has been taken over by the
government there was the Taiwan
high-speed rail program they have lost
two-thirds of their capital at this
point and they have now had their their
franchise extended from thirty five
years to ninety nine years hoping that
they can recover the fact is there is no
market for this that can support
commercial operations yeah so the
fundamental truth is is that this is a
this is an idea that still isn't ready
for primetime and then the California
one doesn't even take advantage of the
strengths that high-speed rail has so
it's really it's really I think a
fantasy project well thanks Wendell I
appreciate you you having a chat about
this with me and and with the rest of
the folks on reason TV
you